in london this morning queen elizabeth
joined other members of the royal family
to give thanks for the life of prince
philip who died nearly a year ago he was
99 at the time it was the queen's first
public event since testing positive for
covet last month now this service was a
larger celebration of phillips life and
legacy after covert restrictions limited
the size of his funeral roxanna siberia
is outside westminster ami were abby
rather where the service has just ended
roxanna good morning to you so he did
have a proper celebration today of his
life that's good
he did gail good morning around 1800
guests were invited here among them
british and international royalty and
members of charities the prince
supported but today was not only about
the service it was also about who
attended and who didn't
from the hymns to the guests prince
philip finally got the service he had
planned nearly a year after his death a
celebration of his life and legacy
as britain's longest-serving royal
consort supporting his wife queen
elizabeth for around seven decades
after a lot of speculation she attended
the 95 year old had cut back on her
public appearances since spending a
night in the hospital last october and
catching kovit last month she has
mobility issues some days are better
than others royal correspondent roy
anika says this was the queen's most
important engagement in perhaps the last
decade why was it so important for the
queen to be here she wanted to be here
in order to show her is pay her respects
to pay tribute and also to thank all the
people who've come together to honor him
today
at prince philip's funeral last april
pandemic restrictions meant only 30
people were allowed inside this was his
son prince andrew's first public
appearance since settling a sexual
assault case in the u.s brought by
virginia du frey she had claimed the
late sex offender jeffrey epstein
trafficked her to the prince and while
grandson prince william and wife kate
attended prince harry stayed in the u.s
no longer a working member of the royal
family he's in a legal dispute with the
british government over security
arrangements for him and his young
family when they travel to the uk
still his spokesperson says the prince
plans to visit the queen as soon as
possible
and she has yet to beat harry and
megan's daughter lilibet she was named
after the queen and born shortly after
the death of prince philip vlad roxanna
seberry and london thank you roxanna
it's good to see the queen it's always
good to see the queen that she appears
to be in good health and such a lovely
turnout and tribute to philip you know
the queen her jubilee celebration is
coming up so hopefully harry megan and
the kids will be able to come then yeah
i love the word you believe by the way i
do too one of the great words in the
english language i like that word